[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of fandango indie
movie Guide my second little Oscar
special this time taking a look at the
Supporting Actor categories the nominees
are Willem Dafoe Woody Harrelson Richard
Jenkins Christopher Plummer and Sam
Rockwell now taking a look at each of
these nominees more closely Willem Dafoe
is nominated for the Florida project
which is directed by Shawn Baker it's
all about the hidden homeless living on
the outskirts of Disney World in Florida
and this is Willams third Oscar
nomination he's also the only person in
this film to be nominated and in fact
it's the only nomination the Florida
Project picked up okay I warned it one
drip in you're out
three billboards though has two nominees
in the same category with Sam Rockwell
and Woody Harrelson the last time that
happened was in 1991 with Bugsy we're
both Harvey Keitel and Sir Ben Kingsley
were nominated Sam Rockwell picked up
the Golden Globe for this role but this
is actually his first ever Oscar
nomination Woody Harrelson has been
nominated two other times before making
this his third nomination we've had two
official complaints about those
billboards from who the lady was a funny
eye a lady with a funny the shape of
water has done really well overall with
Oscar nominations particularly in the
acting categories here in Best
Supporting Actor we have Richard Jenkins
this is his second Oscar nomination and
he picks this one up for playing the
neighbor and accomplice to Sally Hawkins
character in the shape of water if I
told him about her what would I say all
the money in the world was largely
overlooked by the Academy except for
Christopher Plummer who is nominated for
Best Supporting Actor at 88 years old it
also makes him the all-time oldest
acting Oscar nominee the previous record
was held by the 87 year old Gloria
Stewart who's in Titanic do not have the
money to spare no one has ever been
richer than you are at this moment what
would it take for you to feel secure
more so really were the contenders here
but my prediction is going to Sam
Rockwell for his role in three
billboards outside Epping Missouri now
this role has been a little bit
controversial lately with many people
upset rightly so that a racist character
such as his gets somewhat of a
Redemption towards the end of the film
but I'm predicting this based on all the
other award shows thus far and the Oscar
buzz behind Sam Rockwell now to Best
Supporting Actress and the nominees are
mary j blige Allison Janney Lesley
Manville Laurie Metcalf and Octavia
Spencer so starting with mary j blige
this is her very first Oscar nomination
for her work in mud bound directed by D
Reese this is a period film which looks
a lot at racism and classism during the
times of world war ii and mary j blige
is not only nominated here for her first
ever oscar but she's actually nominated
for two Oscars this year also up for
Best Original Song for her song mud
bound which appears in the film I held
his heartbeat in my head all the time he
was gone only pre-fit
I Tania could give allison janney her
very first Oscar when she plays the
mother to Tonya Harding and Miss biopic
of sorts of the Tonya Harding story and
this was actually a role that was
written for her she won the Golden Globe
in this category and this is actually
her first Oscar nomination call out a
clean skate stop talking to her that
girl is your enemy
[Music]
the nomination for Lesley Manville for
phantoms red it wasn't necessarily
predicted but it is definitely welcomed
this is Leslie's first Oscar nomination
as well but she is no stranger to award
shows and she's probably most well known
to audiences for her work with Mike Lee
for example in another year may I warn
you of something my brother can feel
cursed that love is doomed for him
it's also hard to believe that Laurie
Metcalf has never been nominated for an
Oscar before she picked up her very
first nomination for Lady Bird where she
plays the mother to Scioscia Ronan's
character and their relationship which
is so relatable to watch is the center
of this entire movie and one of the main
reasons this movie works so well should
just go to City College you know with
your work ethic just go to City College
and then to jail and then back to City
College and then maybe you'd learn to
pull yourself off everybody and with her
nomination in the shape of water Octavia
Spencer also reaches a record she is the
third actress since 2000 to get three or
more Best Supporting Actress nominations
this is her third amy adams has for that
Cate Blanchett also has three and in the
shape of water she is also an accomplice
to Sally Hawkins character playing a
fellow janitor working in this shady
government lab don't do this Eliza don't
do this
so to my prediction each of those ladies
are very much worthy of the Goldman
statue but I'm gonna go with Allison
Janney for AI Tania again like Sam
Rockwell she's the one that's been
picking up a lot of awards and like Sam
Rockwell's character in three billboards
her role in hi Tania is not without
controversy with many people saying than
it treats domestic abuse just a little
bit too lightly being that it is a dark
comedy but given that she has won so
many so far and I think there's a lot of
lot of momentum behind her I'm going
with Allison Janney next week on this
show I'm gonna delve into the lead actor
categories but if you want to get a head
start and have a look at someone who is
the front-runner right now for Best Lead
Actor then you can see darkest hour
available at home on Fandango now this
stars an unrecognizable Gary Oldman as
Winston Churchill at the time when he
was Prime Minister of Britain right when
it was the darkest hour of the war it's
a brilliant companion piece to Dunkirk
or if you're watching the crown like I
am it also focuses on that time and Gary
Oldman is just remarkable it's way more
than the makeup and the prosthetics
which are impressive but it's an entire
body performance you can see darkest
hour on Fandango now right now
for Williams victory there can be no
survival
so in the comments below or on Twitter
adulation Malone I want to know what do
you think about my predictions for Best
Supporting Actor Best Supporting Actress
do you agree with them or do you think
someone else may surprise us all let me
know and I'll see you next week
[Music]